dozens of people are in hospital after a
gas explosion in Paris set several
buildings on fire the blast in the
city's Fifth District caused the front
of one building to collapse firefighters
are on the scene battling the Flames
whilst police are trying to keep people
away Dasha Butler joins us now from
Paris and task you're at the scene
you're as close as you can get tell us
what you can see there
yeah we're just a few streets away this
is where police have allowed us to get
to and if I just step out you might be
able to see at the end of this street of
firefighters and some police officers
that have been at the scene I mean I
think I can actually see a stretcher
down there and an ambulance somebody on
it so they have been working very hard
Emergency Services uh since uh around
five o'clock which is when we first
heard a large explosion I was actually
very close to this area I heard this
explosion thought it was a sonic boom it
only became clear a little while after
that it was something else because there
was a huge Bloom of smoke in uh the air
some eyewitnesses talked about how
windows were rattling somebody who lived
nearby said to me that they felt as if
their apartment was shaking what we know
now is that police are saying that it's
likely that a gas explosion caused a
building to collapse and Spark fires in
adjacent building that building that
collapsed was the Paris American Academy
we now know it's a fashion School in
fact one of the teachers from that
school was here a little while earlier
very concerned because he hadn't heard
from some of his friends although there
were no classes going on at the time of
course there are still people working in
and around the building and if you just
look this way you probably see uh some
police officers but also we are
surrounded by a number of residents
who've been trying to get home or trying
to ascertain what has happened to their
apartment building they're of course
very shaken and worried about any damage
there might be and of course about
anyone they know that could be injured
absolutely because there's a little bit
more about the area that you're in this
is a huge explosion to have happened in
the middle of a city
precisely a huge explosion in the middle
of Paris we're in uh the fifth of rondi
small it is quite an upscale part of the
city very close to the famous Luxembourg
Gardens where tourists like to go
parisians like to enjoy them too and it
is a residential area and look Paris is
a very densely populated city apartment
blogs and people in the street this is
the sort of time when this explosion
happened around five o'clock a sort of
time when children are going home from
school where people are starting to
filter away going home from work so
there would have been uh people in the
street there would have been people in
the street anywhere as they always are
in Paris because as I said it is such a
densely populated city and that is why
it is such a concern and why emergency
services are keeping people away they
want to make sure that they have really
searched through the area there are
still people that are believed to be
missing that haven't been accounted for
they weren't necessarily here but their
families don't know where they are so
that is why Emergency Services still
very much cordoning off this area until
they know that people can be let back in
okay Natasha Butler joining us there
from Central Paris where that explosion
happened a couple of hours ago thanks
very much Natasha